posséder une arme en france est
condamnable un maximum de six ans en
prison tu es quelqu'un lui poussant une
pièce dessus condamnable à 18 h jeux
peuvent être imposées sur une vidéo de
squeeze et condamnable à plus de dix ans
de prison
après il ya eu deux explosions
nonobstant sur un jeu ce week-end va
devoir deviner laquelle des deux
infractions proposé engendre une peine
d'au moins x années et aujourd'hui est
un grand jour puisque j'ai bien expliqué
le but du jeu puis tâche propre aux
comptes applaudissements par exemple là
on a le trafic sexuel des enfants de
moins de 14 ans je pense que tu prennes
pas de grosse peine dans la gueule et en
face on a la possession d'une arme à feu
ou de munitions par un fugitif ou
toxicomanes qui a trois condamnations
pour crimes violents pour infractions
relatives aux drogues
y a pas plus près six mois et coûté juge
ouais je sais je suis inspecteur je suis
beaucoup de choses j'ai un fils de [ __ ]
hausse mais avant tout un juge et je
pense que faire du trafic sexuel
j'avais même pas parler tellement ça me
fait quelque chose horrible ceux des
enfants de moins de 14 ans tu te prends
perpète donc la peine la plus petite est
logiquement la possession d'armes à feu
je pense à passer pareille 15 ans dans
les deux cas à temps la vie est injuste
voilà c'est tout pour moi abonnés
deuxième question le trafic sexuel
d'enfants mais questionné lutins vite
sexuel là je commence à me poser des
questions sur les gens concret jeu
bordel le trafic sexuel d'enfants ayant
plus de 14 ans mais moins de 18 ans par
la force et la programme temps sinon
plus de 18 ans et ça s'appelle des
adultes plus des enfants mais ok ok
j'arrête
en face nous avons causés aux conspiré
pour causer des dommages ou la
destruction d'un véhicule à moteur
transportant des déchets radioactifs de
haute activité ou du combustible
nucléaire usé avec l'intention d'être en
danger la sécurité plus ma phrase au
temple un juge doit avoir une
respiration mon gars écouter fait
confiance aux juges quizy tu prend
forcément plus dans la gueule
voulant faire du trafic sexuel qu'en
voulant péter un véhicule qui transporte
des déchets radioactifs 30 ans tu prends
30 ans pète aura pas de voitures qui
transporte détruire des actifs et tu
prends dix ans seulement 20 du trafic
sexuel
c'est injuste abonnés alors dans mon
raisonnement j'ai eu faux mais j'ai
quand même eu bon mais en fait j'avais
pas vu mais fallait fallait cliquer sur
celle où tu prends une peine d'au moins
30 ans ce qu'on a fait jusqu'où il est
fort même endommagé ont tenté
d'endommager une propriété des us avec
du feu ou des explosifs simorre s'ensuit
face à engager une conduite explicite
avec un enfant dans le but de produire
toute représentation visuelle d'un tel
comportement
simorre s'ensuit h pas tout compris à 7
cm
dans quels cas tu te prends 30 ans bien
géré le premier mon gars n'ont même pas
ok
quel on a gagné deux procès sur trois
dans quels cas tu te prends une peine
d'au moins trente ans on la
falsification d'un saut de notaire ouais
impose claquer du juge tchèque ou la
vente d'un enfant par des parents ou un
tuteur légal aux fins d'exploitation
sexuelle beaux mecs baïkal et sans
hésiter la deuxième fois là-bas
wheelbase rocha a tu prends que un
manque de falsifier un seul notaire loi
dit un peu plus quand même elle va
mettre une tête de mort pour ça mais non
la peine de mort c'est terrible ce coup
de faire ta gueule c'est qu'il juge
c'est ce qu'il juge c'est qu'il juge
c'est c'est qu'il juge c'est qu'il juge
c est qu il juge cette voie là alors la
gueule ces infractions gendre un
emprisonnement d'au minimum 5 ans celle
de gauche pas besoin de lire la
production possession réception
transport de représentation visuelle
obscène de l'abus sexuel d'enfants
arrêter avec les enfants laissés
l'europe et la fabrication distribution
ou possession avec l'intention de
distribuer de toul alex un ou deux des
médicaments de drogues synthétiques
elle elle prend puisque cinq ans je
pense donc j'irai juin [ __ ] c'est pas
là à temps je suis au ps
lorsque tu prends au moins cinq ans pour
le les trucs des enfants qui paulo tu
prends plus olalalala [ __ ] mais fait
que vous jugez par squeeze quoi la
justice sur la côte est violent alors
laquelle de ces deux infractions pour un
minimum de dix ans l'exercice de la
pharmacie et la vente de poisons en
chine
importation exportation illégale pas de
mort ou de blessures graves quoi tu
prends que un mois que tu vends des
poisons chimiques c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien les jeux comme ça c'est que
des fois t'es étonné des fois ça
t'étonne de ouf les phrases ok ok to
watch câble en question suivante
laquelle de ces infractions engendre un
emprisonnement d'au minimum 25 ans la
trahison a sachez que c'est puni vénère
la violation des interdictions relatives
à des armes atomiques
aucun des six résultant tu prends 25 ans
pour les deux avants trahison tout
casser sur cinq ans pour trahison et 25
ans ont lieu cinq ans les traîtres josé
de la trahison c'était violent quoi de
moi je me croise une dictature simple
laquelle de ces deux infractions
engendré peine d'un minimum de 5 ans
connaître le transport inter étatiques
l'expédition la vente ou la position
avec l'intention de vendre des
représentations visuelles d'un mineur se
livrant à un croisement sexuellement
explicites
ok certains étrangers avec l'intention
ou avec des raisons de croire que
l'étranger va commettre un crime illégal
jawad jaurès est pour toi
m'a demandé de rendre service j'ai rendu
service monsieur assis à votre avis
jawad a pris une peine d'au moins cinq
ans banon avait après le premier c'est
avoir connaissance du coup je pense que
c'est juste la première voie là et j'ai
envie de baisser jusqu'à trois ans de
prison à chaque fois jawad pu réfléchir
à deux fois avant d'héberger des gens
laquelle de ces infractions gens d'une
peine d'un viol de cinq ans
l'instruction sur des terres fédérales
pour la chasse ou le tir j'ai toute
personne engagée dans à cause de la
performance de ses fonctions officielles
en tant qu'inspecteur de volailles de
produits de volaille ya le pen précise
si tu but
un inspecteur de volailles ce que
faisait bizarre j'ai coûté 3 5 ans moi
je pense que c'est pour aller chasser
outin et son éclairage cinq jours assez
nul est par contre tu prends la mort ou
l'emprisonnement filles de 8 à tuer
quelqu'un [ __ ] je suis débile mais
qu'elle juge je suis plutôt bien
apprécié en train d'un minimum de 30 ans
la soustraction la fraude ou de faux
centre et partons agents bancaires ou
l'achat d'un enfant aux fins
d'exploitation sexuelle arrive [ __ ]
j'en ai marre non mais là c'est petit
toit timothée mathieu david je suis
désolé je pense que quand tu achètes un
enfant pour faire assure sexuelles avec
tu as tout de suite la peine de mort et
même si t'as pas la peine de mort père
de sept enfants d'infliger la peine de
mort deux ans quand la fraude et où es
tu prends 30 ans je prends pas une bonne
pen ne fait en fait ce n'est pas un pays
aussi moi je suis pas un juge aux us je
suis pas un juge dans les états via la
peine de mort tuer un juge en france
alors laquelle de ces infractions
engendre une peine de un mois ont refusé
de témoigner devant le congrès ouais ou
kidnappés un mineur tu prends que un
mois quand tu qui n'a pas un mineur non
tu prends plus je pense
voilà oui voilà tu prends 20 ans petit
fils d'un verre je me disais juste
choisir l'action mâchant des frais sur
des prix ou alors pour la prise d'otage
entraîné la mort de quelqu'un voilà tu
prends la mort ou la prison à vie
organisée ou gérer l'entreprise qui
encaisse 5 millions de 24 mois ou alors
tuer tuer le cheval d'un policier moi tu
prends la prison à l'emprisonnement à
vie que tu joues à l'implicite [ __ ] à
c ur messieurs dames c'est la fin du
premier trimestre n'a maintenant notre
relevé les notes qu'elle est notre
moyenne générale 14 sur 20 ça défonce sa
défense attendez je vous donne ma carte
comme ça si vous avez un procès vous
pouvez m'appeler pour
votre cas les carnets visite ça c'est
une carte sd tuerie [ __ ] tu ris la
tuerie curie leurs baskets
oh là là je vais te dire l'art à prendre
une peine de 10 ans pour deux blagues
d'affilée cohen comme cette vidéo sur
j'aime pas je sais toujours pas dans ce
jeu mais un lien suivrait tester c'est
gratuit c'est sympa on fait un match
comme ça parce que comme je disais tu
apprends pas mal de trucs et surtout
tout ce qui est chez condamnation pour
les peines y avait des trucs très précis
et très bizarre dans la loi qui sont
marqués mais c'est pas bien dur sur sa
pelouse autorise une prochaine portez
vous bien un chat ou pis
[Musique]